hey what is up guys
so blackberry doesn't make that many
phones anymore but this is the newest
one it's called the BlackBerry Prive
this is a smartphone made by blackberry
right but it runs Android I said before
it would take a lot for me to actually
review a blackberry but this one this
one's actually not bad no seriously it's
not bad at all so right off the top for
a blackberry this phone is quite nice
it's my favorite blackberry ever but in
the vast array of smartphones out now
I'd say it's pretty middle-of-the-road
average first of all with the build it's
got the quite a few things going for it
obviously it's a vertical slider so
that's pretty unique as far as
smartphones go but when the keyboard is
closed it's actually pretty clean the
carbon fiber look all the way around the
body the squared off top and bottom and
the texture the material itself is
actually really grippy both on the back
and on the rails on the sides too so
this is the phone that does not need a
skin or case it's never slid out of my
pocket once never slid off a desk it's
probably the most secure feeling phone
I've ever held it's got the power button
on the left and the trio of buttons on
the right so volume up volume down and
the toggle for volume control reminds me
of other blackberries and there's also a
front facing speaker actually on the
bottom too now it's really barely an
average speaker is pretty weak as far as
quality goes but it's facing the user so
it's still better than anything
rear-facing and then right above that
speaker is a lip for you to grab the
keyboard and that's where you can slide
it open and close with one hand and I
got used to this motion in a matter of
minutes and then over the course of
weeks of using the device it felt
correct pretty quickly the spring
mechanism for opening it is solid feels
durable and confident when the phone is
open and it actually feels more balanced
when it's open when the weight is spread
out more it doesn't feel top-heavy at
all my only complaint with the build is
the thin back cover material I feel like
since it's sealed in phone you could use
whatever material you want but the back
just feels soft and thin and kind of
flexes now on paper again this is the
best blackberry ever snapdragon 808 chip
two gigabytes of ram 32 gigs of internal
storage but that's also expandable
inside a 3410 milliamp hour battery with
wireless charging and quick charging and
a 5.4 inch quad HD AMOLED display with
slightly curved edges on both sides now
among the other top smartphones it's
kind of sitting mid
high-end but still refreshing to see
this in a Blackberry so the battery life
I got was meh decent like b-minus
territory I was getting barely three
hours of screen on time and the screen
itself is pretty good not the best quad
HD AMOLED display I've seen which is
sort of a weird statement to make now
but it's true and it's still plenty
sharp but could be brighter and a bit
more saturated but it's a quality panel
and all of this under all the BlackBerry
logos and hardware it runs android 5.1
under the hood and it's actually pretty
close to stock android i wouldn't really
call it a skin more of a vanilla Android
with a bunch of blackberry enhancements
and added features thrown in kind of
like what Motorola does with their Moto
X and this is kind of where blackberry
goes to town they added a ton of stuff
mixing in classic older blackberry
features with new stuff and Android so
you can swipe up from the bottom to not
just get Google now but also blackberry
device search and blackberry hub I found
Google now does a pretty good job of
searching the device anyway but I didn't
use blackberry hub that much because
it's sort of overwhelming it's a
collection of all of your notifications
from email and Twitter etc everything
shows up there you can also use icon
packs from the Play Store in the custom
launcher it's not Google launcher but
it's very similar plus this feature and
it also has a feature called pop-up
widgets which lets you swipe up from
certain icons on your homescreen to just
show their widgets and this is already
sort of a feature in some other
third-party Android launchers but hey
it's built in now here and it's
occasionally pretty useful especially I
guess for music and media apps there's
also a redesigned slightly crazy-looking
multitasking tray with like different
apps of different sizes not sure why but
that's the way it is and you also now
have double tap to wake but no double
tap to sleep I always say this I think
every phone that has the option to
double tap to wake should also let you
double tap to sleep it also sorts your
notifications in the tray so you can
target certain apps when you have
multiple notifications from apps and
over here on the side of your curved
display is what's called the
productivity tab you swipe in from the
side kind of like the tab on the Galaxy
s6 edge and it shows full screen
calendar events contacts tasks all sorts
of stuff I kind of wish I could throw in
some app shortcuts in there but that
would take a software update it also
throws in this sweet charging indicator
and ambient display since it's an AMOLED
display and you can do
things without using much battery and
pretty much all these new additions are
pretty intuitive and clean and easy to
figure out what's weird though is that
despite that pretty solid set of specs
we talked about this guy has more
hitches than a normal Android phone I
found animations slowing down a bit and
dropping a little frames more than I'd
want to see out of the Snapdragon 808
device especially when multitasking and
web browsing and switching between a
bunch of stuff it's funny because gaming
and intense stuff was perfectly fine
graphics held up and it didn't drop any
frames everything was totally smooth but
for some reason the quicker lighter
stuff actually took some hits and it
definitely got warm they never
overheated or anything but I could
definitely feel it in that fin back
after extended use now I'm sure software
updates including an update to
marshmallow hopefully will fix a lot of
these issues and even extend battery
life a bit with those but for now that's
my experience and then since it is a
Blackberry after all there's a little
focus on the keyboard and the typing
experience so the software keyboard is
pretty good but if you don't like it
like I didn't you can replace it with
the Google keyboard or anything else if
you want it's Android and the hardware
keyboard is alright I'm personally not a
huge fan and look I like hardware
keyboards I started off my smartphone
career with the Moto droid that thing
had an awesome keyboard but the keys
were a lot bigger this blackberry Prive
is a vertical slider and all the keys
feel tiny and very close together a
little too close for my fingers but I
understand not everyone's hands are huge
so here are some tricks for people who
will really use this physical keyboard
so you can swipe left to delete one word
at a time so if you made a typo or
something and you just want to delete it
you get the satisfying gesture to get
rid of words and then if you want to be
a little more precise you can double tap
to enter cursor mode and that's just a
little little touch on the keyboard it's
not actually pressing keys then it acts
like a touchpad you can actually move
around to choose where you want to type
and this touchpad behavior can work in
other apps too so you can scroll through
Twitter or Phoenix or Instagram or
Chrome or whatever just by swiping along
the top of the keyboard which is pretty
cool
might seem like a gimmick at first but
all this stuff works really well to keep
your fingers off the display so you can
see the whole display while you're using
it alright last thing in touch on with
this Prive is the camera on the back
probably less important on a blackberry
but continuing on the theme it's better
than any other blackberry camera
but it's really nothing special it's an
18 megapixel shooter with oh is and the
dual LED flash on the back and it's
capable of some pretty mediocre looking
for K video and the photos it takes it
has this really steep quality curve from
high light to low light in high light
the photos look fine nice and sharp and
detailed and have accurate color not a
whole lot of dynamic range and
highlights do blow out all the time but
it looks fine but then very quickly once
you start to lose light the photos get
way worse and every smartphone camera
suffers in low-light but yeah this one
really takes a hit you get plenty of
noise and artifacts and processing just
looks a little out of whack here the
camera app itself is really clean
nothing wrong with it except that it's
really slow to actually take a photo why
is there that much shutter lag I like
that I have exposure control with a neat
little slider down there at the bottom
but yeah the camera app needs an update
for a lot of these things to be fixed oh
and the front-facing 2-megapixel camera
is a joke so what do we learn with this
phone well BlackBerry has a whole bunch
of good ideas lots of productivity
tricks and neat shortcuts and things
like that but not enough to win me over
personally I used it kind of like a
normal Android phone not a premium
blackberry and it was just alright you
might like it but I think I'll wait for
the prove too thanks for watching and
I'll talk to you guys the next one peace
you